(people talking in background)
- Oh, shit!
- (scoffs) Hi, are you okay?
- Just pretend I'm not even here.
- Oh, okay.
Sorry, I'm just very aware of
how close you are to my bum.
Is this a game I don't know about?
Oh, is this planking?
- No, no, I'm hiding.
- From an ex?
- Technically.
More like an ex-roommate?
(soft piano music playing)
- Hey, are you June?
- Yeah.
- Tiffany wants you to
have your stuff back.
- What, she couldn't face me herself?
- She's busy.
(soft piano music playing)
(keyboard tapping)
- (gasping) Tiffany's travel mug.
(gasping) Her pen!
Her hair tie, oh, this is mine.
(girls talking softly)
Hey, Tiffany.
- Hey June, this is my
new roommate, Lilly.
- Hey, what's up?
- New roommate.
- Yeah.
- Cool.
"Oh, I'm Lilly, I like to party
and have fun all the time."
You're gonna get sick of her! (sobbing)
(soft piano music playing)
(rain falling)
- Wow.
Was she really that good of a roommate?
- No.
But you know, nobody likes change.
- Oh, hey June.
- Hey, Tiffany.
Oh, this is, uh--
- Bridget, Junes's new roommate.
- Oh, really.
- Yeah, she's loads of fun.
I haven't stopped laughing
since I moved in. (giggles)
- Yeah, I bet.
- Well, it's Roommates
Day Out, right, June?
Must go.
- Yeah.
- Nice to meet you, Theresa.
- But, it's Tiffany!
- Oh my god, thank you so much.
- Honestly, don't mention it.
- You don't even know
how much you helped me.
- Oh, shit, I'm late for Psych class.
It was so lovely running into you.
I'll see you around.
- Oh, shit.
(uptempo instrumental music)